hello everyone Joshua Waitzkin is
definitely one of my favorite chess
players well he was one of my favorite
chess players as he gave up on chess
long ago he simply lost interest in
chess and well as he says it one day he
was playing a chess game and it didn't
really matter to him what was happening
on the board he was more concerned about
how he looked or how he appeared to
others while playing the game and this
all happened after the movie searching
for Bobby Fischer came out which is well
the movie is about him as he's supposed
to be the next Bobby Fischer but this
game was played he was 11 years old and
he's playing it's the New York Open
tournament in 1987 against an American
film master Edward Franken and it's well
it's an amazing game and it features one
of my favorite rook lifts to ever have
been played and one other thing if you
happen to have a chance to try and get
your hands on a chess master grand
master 11 edition or it's chess master
11 grandmaster edition I believe it
features an Academy by Josh Waitzkin and
it's well I really enjoyed it I believe
I learned a lot and it's an it's an
excellent piece of software also if
you're able to try and get your hands on
the book the art of learning by by
Joshua Waitzkin
it's also an amazing book the audio book
is also available I think you can find
some free samples on the internet and
also on YouTube just you know if you've
never heard of George whites can just
try and listen to how he explains chess
and what it's all about and how to learn
anything pretty much ok so let's see the
game a young josh is white and he plays
efore we have c5 by Frumkin the Sicilian
defense Knight to f3 d6 we have d4c
captors and e4 Knight captures on d4 and
Knight to f6 Knight to c3 and Knight to
c6 now the four Knights variation of the
Sicilian Bishop to e3
we have Bishop to b4 and f3 in defending
the e4 pawn d5 and we have Bishop to b5
now pinning that night Franklin goes for
Bishop to d7
although Queen to c7 would would be a
better move as you'll see later Bishop
to d7 and now Josh plays Bishop captures
on c6 and given up the bishop pair but
with an idea
B captures on c6 and now II five and now
well this night doesn't really have
anywhere to go
you don't really want to go to h5
because you'll get g4 and now this
Bishop is blocking Knights path to d7 so
he has to play Knights to g8 we have a
three Bishop to a5 and now b4 Bishop to
c7 attacking e5 and f4 and already you
can see that the White has created well
it might not be a better position but
it's much more comfortable to play this
position for white he doesn't really
have a light square bishop but he will
he will use the Knights to cover the
light squares and well this darks with
this light square Bishop of blacks and
e7 isn't really much of a threat Knight
to e7
we're Knight to a4 Josh wants to occupy
this strong c5 square for his knight
from king castles and we had Knight to
c5 with a 5 c3 and night to c7 although
it might be better for this knife to
remain on the King side to help out with
the defense around the King from King
decides to go for the idea Knight c8
Knight b6 and night c4 this is a great
square for the knight Josh castles and
we have knife to b6 Queen to g4 and now
Knight to c4 attacking the bishop on e3
Bishop to f2 and we have Queen to e8
rook F to e 1 preparing the rook for for
a rook lift if it will be possible later
Bishop with the c8 now preparing to
activate this bishop after this night
and c8 on c5 moves Bishop to h4 and King
to h8 and this King to h8 is a pretty
important move
if white would if black would continue
with Bishop to a sex for example this
loses the game immediately to Bishop to
f6 the thread is of course Queen
captures and g7 checkmate
so after g6 Queen to g5 there really is
no defense against Queen h6 and Queen to
g7 checkmate
so after Bishop to h4 from Queen played
a king to h8 and we have a four now as
this pond was attacked by the night
so this rook couldn't really move and
also this is preparing ideas like b5 and
also if a captor stand before C captor
some before will create a very strong
best a pawn Bishop to b6 now preparing
to get rid of the knight and activate
the light square Bishop rook a to D 1 we
have Bishop captures on c5 b captures on
c5 and now from King doesn't doesn't
activate the bishop with Bishop to a6
immediately he plays Knight to be to
gaining a tempo on this rock and e1 and
also well this comes with a double
attack on the pawn on a4 and probably
from Queen thought that young Waitzkin
will go for rook back to a-1 to defend
his a for pawn but this is where Josh
gets gets a beautiful idea and place
this amazing rock lift he plays rook to
e3 and what is the idea here
he's given up well it seems like he's
giving up at the exchange but probably
from Ken didn't think that he was going
for the exchange
he thought that well Josh was just
trying to trying to quicken his King
side attack with Knight captures and e1
and then rook to g3 or roof to h3
depending depends on what how from Cain
would defend so he grabbed the rook he
played Knight captures on d1 and well
unfortunately for him rook to g3 was
never a really Josh's idea
eleven-year-old Josh although maybe he
was 10
I don't really know played King captures
on g7 with Czech sacrificing his queen
and well it was in this position already
that young Josh said that his father was
going crazy you know
you had such a nice game while you have
to blunder your rook and then after he
saw this Quinta g7 move that he was well
if he was devastated only move King
captures on g7 and now comes Bishop to
f6 with the check and there's really
nowhere black King can go if King to g8
you get rocked the g3 immediately with
checkmate so instead he played King to
g6 King to h6 who wouldn't make any
difference
Rock to g3 with check King 286 now
Bishop to g7 with check King to h5 on
the move and now Rock to g5 with check
King has to go to h4 and now I'm sure
you can all see Josh's finishing move
it's Knight to f3 with checkmate and
well from candy together rockin d1 but
he also got his King on h4 so yeah
definitely definitely a beautiful game
by the 10 11 year-old Josh and a pretty
amazing King hunt probably from pin just
underestimated the little fellow and he
thought well he doesn't really have
anything here but interestingly after he
captures this rook on d1 it's it's it's
completely forced checkmate in 6 moves
there is no defense whatever black plays
so yeah if I'm not sure if he calculated
it out that he probably he probably
wouldn't have captured the rook but I
guess he just thought that it was a
blunder by young Josh so yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it as usual
you can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon